[Music]
so we finally have a trailer of Godzilla
and Kong the new Empire and it tells us
a lot at where the monsterverse is right
now and also raises countless questions
to which we will answer each and every
one of them in future videos we won't do
a breakdown or a reaction video those
are a dime a dozen by now for this video
today we will take a look only at
Godzilla's new evolved form and compare
him to the previous ones so let's get to
it so obviously let's start with size
firstly there isn't much of a difference
that one can see here with his height
Godzilla was 90 M or 300 ft in 1954 as
was seen in Monarch the legacy of
monsters then grew to be 355 ft or 108 m
in his first appearance in
2014 then he fought with with the muto
Prime and evolved further to grow to a
size of 393 ft or 120 m in height as for
this gxk Godzilla he does look leaner
and has bigger dorsal plates which we
shall address in a few seconds so it
might be that he has grown slightly
taller with his pink plates giv an extra
few meters and also when he was running
with Kong to get some big mags he does
appear to be visibly a lot taller than
he was against Kong in
GVK now let's take a look at the most
controversial change in Godzilla which
is obviously this his pink amethyst type
dorsal plates he looks like an evil Goku
in Super Saiyan Rose form these dozle
plates whether you like them or not
isn't the first time godzill has had
them in this shade this design is
heavily influenced or copied from
Godzilla Millennium or Godzilla 2000 heu
has these pink crystal-like spikes on
his back the ones on the monsterverse
Godzilla seems to jut out from many
different places is giving him a most
spiky and dangerous look in fact they
start right from the head with three
distinct rows emerging just above his
eyes and his forehead they continue
along the back molting and growing over
the previous plates adding height to the
Titan as well as energy these end of
course with the tail which Bears the
same dorsal plates and in fact if the
leaks are true he will have a
Stegosaurus like Spike at the
end okay let's go forth to his arms and
legs this Godzilla in this particular
evolved form has probably the longest
arms to body ratio of any other Godzilla
be it from the monsterverse or from the
Toho movies the arm length was also
changed greatly during his Evolution
period under the crysalis probably in
reaction to his fight with Mecha
Godzilla where his upper body strength
and speed and the use of his arms was
greatly outdone by the robotic
counterpart the elbows have Crystal
spikes on it and the claws have also
grown longer the legs of his is where I
feel a bit sad though they appear to be
athletic and not thick anymore looks
like he has been losing weight and not
in the right places damn boy we all love
those massive thighs and heavy feet but
it's all right though we'll grow to love
these new assets
too so after the limbs let's take a look
at the changes in his upper torso the
skin the chest and the belly so with
this new design the skin looks to be or
have a whitish appearance on it which at
first we thought was ice and snow from
the glacier but when it showed the same
in the desert scene and when he was
running we knew then and there that his
coloration has also changed from the
base up it's not just that but the skin
near the dosel plates also look to be
yellowish or beige in color like it was
burned by the radiation that is emitted
constantly from the pink dosel plates so
that's that what about his chest it
looks to be similar
and of a similar size it's just the
ratio of the arms head and the greatly
reduced belly that makes the chest look
small so you guys body shamed the king
of the monsters right from 2014 and now
you done it he has lost his belly fat he
went and hit the gym or maybe dream of
the gym in his Crystalis form and then
finally got evolved and got ripped and
also had ABS you know abs of
steel now what about his power strength
and speed so just by looking at the
trailer we can see that his speed is
greatly enhanced we first saw him rush
forward in a running form in fighting
when he was facing gdor in Boston in
king of the monsters then Godzilla
versus Kong showed that he can sustain
this kind of movement for somewhat of an
extended period of time and now in gxk
he seems to be running like a man which
although looks intimidating doesn't
really add to the weight of the
character
all the movements which we really love
the animalistic ones from GVK now he
kind of looks humanoid he seems to be
even faster than Kong who is trying to
keep up in the back so what about
strength well we will have to find that
out when the movie hits the screens he
will almost definitely be more durable
though since he has evolved into a
greater State otherwise what would be
the points or the purpose of it all and
as for the atomic breath let's discuss
this with his comparison to Godzilla
Millennium which we shall do right after
this since we have covered the arms the
legs the skin the Torso the chest the
spikes and the size let's take a look at
him with Godzilla 2000 or otherwise
known as Godzilla Millennium well there
isn't much to compare if it comes to
size and weight the monster was Titan is
way bigger than the 55 M tall 2000 the
Incarnation of Toho but there is one
very important thing you must focus on
aside from the dorsal plates which have
a similar coloration the Millennium
Godzilla's Atomic bread is unique in
that rather than being a whitish mist or
a blue beam it is a fiery orange glow
this version of Godzilla's Atomic breath
appears to be more incendiary in nature
than the previous versions producing a
fiery explosion whenever it is used
whenever Godzilla charges his Atomic
breath his Dorsal fins glow orange and
gives off an intense heat so that's
Godzilla ium so this kind of looks
familiar to gxk Godzilla when he is
charging up his Atomic breath as seen in
the trailer but rather than emitting an
orange glow this changed to a pink or a
magenta color and if it follows the same
Trend then maybe his Atomic breath will
now have an explosive after effect
similar to Godzilla minus 1's nuclear
Cannon as we like to call it and
definitely similar to Godzilla
Millennium lastly let's do a bit of a
comparison to his earlier monsterverse
forms starting with size well we all
know that by now we just stated that in
the video itself earlier on okay let's
do it again 1954 90 M or 300 ft 2014 108
M or 355 ft 2019 and GVK 120 M or 393 ft
and now gxk will probably be more than
400 or close to 410 ft with his enlarged
dorsal plates yeah those Godzilla's
original dosel plates were straight and
Jagged same with the 1954 form 2019 has
a more Maple Leaf shaped and GVK
enhanced this by a bit with a more
intimidating bluish glow now we have the
pink magenta ones so the feet were
always similar in proportions till now
which have now lessened in thickness
while the arms have grown quite a lot
with an added spiky elbow composed of
the same crystall likee uh plates and
lastly his belly is gone with his Atomic
breath bearing a magenta color which
greatly diverts from the normal blue and
those are all the differences Godzilla
in gxk has against the earlier
forms so if you like this video then
watch this one to and do check out our
Channel as well we might just have
things that you haven't seen before from
the monsterverse or other monster movies
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam